oh yeah my shoelace go for it's just
Burberry that's it mm-hmm oh yeah yummy
huh
the first thing I do is I go to my mum's
house and just lay on her bed and tell
her what I want to eat and stay there
for like three three days maybe just
with my family and my friends come and
visit and I just I haven't been home for
so long that I just I think that's what
I miss most my house definitely Zach
Duane is just he such a gentleman so
well-behaved and and just really really
nice and back well hahaha we all would
hang out in somebody's one of their
trailers and just like order food and it
was it was they're completely different
people but both so sweet and just really
nice I do intend to I don't know whether
it'll be a Hindi film or an english
movie yet I just know that I'm in the
middle of assessing films from both here
and there I'll definitely be doing a
movie I just know which one it will be
the one advice that has stuck to me for
a very long time is live and let live we
always we always have an opinion on what
someone's doing and why they're doing it
and they should be doing you know they
shouldn't be doing it and who is anyone
to say what anyone else should do so
live and let live I love that don't try
and be like me trying to be like you I
always wanted to be Priyanka when I grew
up I just I still don't know who that is
but it'll take you a lifetime to figure
out who you are you know you just have
to every single day identify what you
like and what you don't who you are and
what your opinion is and don't let
anyone tell you that you know you're not
your dreams are not worth something or
they you can't be a certain way because
you can be whatever you decide to be and
there are too many girls in the world
were always told that they should behave
a certain way or be a certain way and
that's not right we should all try and
be how we want right okay
adopt a puppy I've been waiting to get a
puppy because my dog is a cocker spaniel
and he's back home in Mumbai was my mom
and I really really miss him but he's
really old he can't travel now he's like
last one man down man down yeah so that
that's definitely something I've been
I've been wanting to do for a while so
this is just really appropriate going
for this yeah no I why are you spinning
just spinning